today's topic chris brown did you hear
what happened no what happened chris
brown had someone um come after him
saying that he wine steamed her and so
it became this big thing and she took
him to court and chris brown has been
pretty silent about these most recent
things for quite some time but recently
chris brown and his lawyers released a
whole series of texts that ranged for a
whole nine months in which this woman
was insistently messaging him with very
little to no responses about getting
back together and hooking up and hooking
up and when chris wouldn't respond and
wouldn't well then after that nine month
period elapsed
she then
said he did something to her
what time is it put the
time to date
you're like
reading the messages and stuff and
you haven't blessed me yet so i'm
guessing you don't hate
me i just want to see you again i mean
just answered the phone and you just
hung up like
just let me know like if you want me to
leave you alone i definitely will but
i really just want to [ __ ] with you
again
mind you during this nine 90 month
period at the beginning she's alleged
that
basically she went to a puff daddy boat
party or something and that's where he
wanted cedar at the party
but then nine months for nine months
after that she was messaging him
incessantly non-stop
now he's basically saying this girl is a
clingy person she's a stalker she won't
leave me alone and now she's trying to
get going my name
that's the general justice story
i guess i could read some of the text so
she's seeking 20 million in damages
because she claims he drugged her at the
young party then afterwards she started
sending him loot photos of herself
basically a bunch of you know
shots she wants to see him again
definitely didn't bust inside you this
was hella faded so i want to be sure
okay babe that's fine
i want to
bang you tonight at midnight and then
i'm
later what you doing and then babe
and then she sends them a message after
a long time hey this is my new number
yeah anyways they've been banging okay
whatever
and
listen nobody knows what really happened
on that evening but again if you
it looks us can we agree at least on
that much looks us
what i do find interesting and i think
what is the main focal point of this
story for me is
when this initially came out the story
initially came out the news were all
over it like usual
chris brown look at him he did it again
blah blah blah blah then when this new
evidence come out not a single person
report on yeah well that's what they've
been doing
because you know you want you already
depicted him as a bad guy
so the bad guy being bad again who that
sales right sales it's a lot
we got a story clicks yeah we get clicks
we get like we get comments i know you
ain't [ __ ] never remember i'm messing
everything we animate we know we don't
know
we don't want we don't want people to
get better you don't want people to
better themselves
right so that's what it is we like that
we like that narrative i like cobra kai
weird why they said that like that it's
[ __ ] up but the reason why i'm saying
this is because all this all these years
all these years you see
uh the character kid
being the winner and the other dude
being the jackass now in cobra kai
you see the opposite
what happened and life is like that
everybody's a bad bad person about
someone bad for a villain to someone
else you understand what i'm saying so
that's that yeah you have to take that
in conservation also whenever people are
not happy when people are not happy with
certain outcome they become vindictive
the vengeance is real
i'm okay i feel like that so you suffer
you should suffer that because this is
not fair
you're gonna you're gonna suffer my
wrath yeah that that's that's
relationship how they work sometimes you
know
so you put
you
you put the news they just take
advantage of that it's just a story that
a story that falls on daylight and they
just take advantage of that
the whole narrative of good good people
bad people nothing in between
they don't want that
they don't ever want people to get
chris brown will do something good they
will never hear about that
and even if he does something about it
and you hear about it in the news people
are going to be like yeah he just want
to do that because he want to look good
he's going to really 20 million in
damage 20 million in damage there's
never a criminal case with these people
20 million 20 million in damages for
you you went back to it and you it's us
that's us sus it really sounds like
vengeance but then again court of public
opinion let's see what the court has to
say
or how does that settlement goes after
out of court but to me it's very sus and
also
some people just trying to come up with
a check that happens
best believe i had scammers try to haul
at me that's happened i don't even make
me money like that so i can only imagine
what chris that's why a lot of these
athletes these famous people assign
waivers they take cell phones away they
do all that stuff before they engage
with anybody because they know it's too
much of a liability to do stuff
otherwise and i'm not saying it's not
some of them who obviously engage in bad
behavior undoubtedly but it just
yeah when they do something wrong we
talk about it uh when it's proven wrong
let's all keep quiet one side of the
aisle gets all the media attention and
by the time it's done it doesn't matter
what happens your brain is always taking
off and he says i'm interested too every
time his album album's about to come out
the pressure comes out too
why because they know even if it's not
true if they put enough media pressure
on him he'll settle because it's going
to be good for the album sales to just
sweep it under the rug so sometimes it's
just a business move which sounds crazy
to people but you can tank stocks you
can tank album sales you can take tours
with just like
just a mere
mention of certain things so
it's like it's it's you can't win
society in a lot of ways and his name is
forever going to be associated with
something that's probably didn't even
happen
that's weird right yeah like you can
never take that off that's that's like
uh that's that's that's a stain that
never whether you're you're you're
you're guilty or not because the news
was so spread around people when
they they had the evidence would not
they heard that you did something it was
so spread but whenever you didn't do
anything and it was found that you
didn't do anything or anything like that
or the opposite that news doesn't go out
as much right
so
there's more people out there that have
this idea and this i don't want you to
do that
yeah you did that you're this and you're
that and you're that and that
but yeah just wanted to bring you this
story let us know what you guys think in
the comments below we want to hear from
you do you think it's fair or not tell
us